what else would be on your syllabus for
teaching young men what they should
focus on in life and
prioritize well you did this early but I
think Fitness just for mental health um
uh getting used to working out early my
dad was in the Royal Navy and he started
me working out when I was like I don't
know 13 and it just s sort of stuck with
me like I didn't do it a lot till I was
17 or 18 but it just sort of was
ingrained in me um I think having a plan
even if that plan changes always just
sort of having a plan always be able to
say if someone asks you what are you
what are you thinking you're going to do
the next five or 10 years you don't have
to stick to it but oh I'm planning to go
to college and then I'm going to get a
degree you know when I was 17 I thought
I was going to be a pediatrician and
chemistry disabused me of that notion um
but always have sort of a plan that you
can articulate to somebody um I would
say uh trying um and this is something I
didn't want to do be more in touch with
your emotions and that is be more honest
with people tell them when you're upset
reach out to people ask for help when a
woman upsets you uh or a friend upsets
you you know it bummed me out that you
didn't call me back or you were not nice
to me in front of the other guys and I
don't understand why I I mean there's a
certain amount of that pecking order and
socialization you need to endure growing
up but I wasn't in touch with my
emotions I didn't tell my mom I loved
her until I was much older and I wish
I'd said that more often I wish that I
had told women and romantic Partners
when my feelings were hurt or how I
truly felt about them I was one of those
guys that would was never wanted to
appear weak or vulnerable so I would
never share my emotions and I think that
screwed up a lot of uh relationships or
diminish them so be much more in touch
with your emotions be much more willing
to express your emotions why what's on
the what's on the other side what's the
positive on the other side of doing that
well there's opportunities to have
friendships and
relationships sometimes sometimes people
are waiting for you to say I'm really
bummed out that maybe you don't want to
be my friend or that you don't like me
as much as I like you and not only that
there's so few people who are willing to
say that at a young age it it
demonstrates
confidence and I think people find that
really attractive I mean and if they
don't that's the wrong kind of person
also you go into this this kind of fun
house of your emotions in a reality
where you don't know what's important to
you you start convincing yourself you
don't care or you don't mind and you
never really get informed my attitude is
when a movie really moves you um ask
yourself why am I inspired by this and
then because that'll help inform what
interests you when something really
upsets you really lean into the upset
and ask why is it upsetting me so much
and otherwise you're just sort of
walking around with blinders on you
don't know really what's important to
you you don't know who you want to spend
time with so to not lean into your
emotions and register them when you give
up a lot because you're going to find
out later in life oh yeah no I liked you
too or no I would have been friends with
you or yeah we were interested in hiring
you but you didn't follow up you weren't
persistent whatever it might be right uh
you should have applied a second time
you should have applied to University
the second time whatever it might have
been right and also you just miss on the
opportunity to feel closer to people and
and have some sense of what's important
to you what inspires you what makes you
sad where you know I don't think I ever
told someone until I was well under my
30s it's something they did upset me I
had this notion that I'm me big strong
man I don't get upset at things I you
know everything deflects off of me I
don't
care yeah I'm uh I've started working
with a therapist over the last few
months here in Austin who worked with a
friend that's way more way more [__]
up than I'll ever be so I figured look
if she can see through his [__] she
can definitely deal with mine and uh
there's layers to this you realize you
know just even talking about your
emotions or being prepared to say them
isn't quite the same as is actually
feeling them feeling them fully you know
having your emotions and your mind rest
where your feet are and uh there's
layers and layers to this that I've
realized especially maybe people that
listen to podcasts like mine or yours
who are interested in Psychology and
human nature and can rationalize or
explain away what they're feeling oh
that's the negativity bias or that's the
abalene Paradox or that's you know I
understand that this is because of my
the it's the B bystander effect or some
other [__] right like they they've
got some mental model that allows them
to explain what's going on inside of
yeah James Clear talks about something
similar and whatever whatever and I
realized that for a good chunk of people
way more than might like to admit it
that's a protection mechanism their
ability to rationalize and explain away
what's happening inside of their minds
gives them an excuse to not have to feel
their feelings
fully I thought of you this last week
and did you see what happened with Caleb
Williams the quarterback for USC no
so this kid is probably GNA I think he's
probably going to be the Heisman Trophy
winner and is probably going to go
number one in the draft and he's playing
against Washington and he blows it and
they're going to lose the guy breaks
down and begins sobbing and immediately
runs over to the stands and jumps up and
Embraces his mother and his mother puts
this notebook over his helmet so that
the crowd can't see him crying and and
his father comes over and consoles him
and I thought oh my God this kid doesn't
even realize he has moved masculinity so
far
forward and the ability to give into
that sort of
emotion and do it publicly you know so
much of this [__] up sense of what it
means to be a man is around bearing your
emotions and when you look at suicide
rates uh and how they're now they used
to be 3:1 male to female and it's
approaching 4:1 one of the key
components of that is men do never learn
how to express they are struggling and
because they're taught from a very early
age that real men don't express that
sort of upset so when you see this guy
who's probably the premier quarterback
in college football this really like big
handsome ridiculously strong guy in
front of national
TV jump up into his mother's arms I mean
it sends such a good signal to young men
that it's okay to be emotional it's okay
to be disappointed I also think that's
such a gift to I mean you're not a
parent yet you really as a parent all
you really want you want two things you
want your kids to be happy and
successful but you also want to comfort
them like any chance you would get as a
parent to comfort your child it's just
so rewarding it's like okay I have
purpose and I remember seeing that
literally the whole nation saw that
moment and I thought that kid
unknowingly just moved masculinity
forward and just reduced the likelihood
or increase the likelihood that a young
man is going to have an easier time
expressing to a family member or
non-family member I am really upset and
that is key to solving that is key to
getting out of a really really dark
place and I thought oh my God it's such
a moving moment so anyways Google uh
Caleb Willams and you'll see the video
it's really it's very raw it's very very
moving and I was just I thought it was
oh God I I I think this kid doesn't
realize uh what a positive role model is
every single morning for over three
years now I have started my day the
exact same way which is with element in
water element contains a science-backed
electrolyte ratio of sodium pottassium
and magnesium and it is the best
hydration drink that I've ever found it
tastes fantastic it's super refreshing
orange is just the most OP flavor in the
world it's absolutely phenomenal and it
helps to play a critical role in
reducing muscle cramps and fatigue it
regulates your appetite it optimizes
brain health and it helps curb Cravings
they're also the exclusive hydration
partner to Team USA weightlifting and
relied on by tons of Olympic athletes
and everyday High performers all around
the world also there is a nobs no
questions asked refund policy where you
can buy a box completely risk-free and
if you do not like it for any reason
they will give you a refund during an
unlimited duration and you don't even
need to return the box that's how comp
confident they are that you love it
element are giving away a free sample
pack of all eight flavors with your
first box if you go to the link in the
description box below or drink lnt.com
MW that's drink LM nt.com
MW what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to
subscribe